Justin, you have, this is a fine cast,
but you have the coolest, deepest register
and of course you're playing the bad guy.
Yeah, I'm the bad guy.
Yeah.
And that must have been fun to channel the bad guy.
All I have is my voice to be the bad guy.
Yeah, it is fun to channel the bad guy
and some of my favorite Lego, not bad guys,
but voices like Will Arnett.
[Conan] Will Arnett.
Famously.
Yeah, yeah.
(crowd cheering)
But he was great as Batman
and then you've seen his truck commercials
where he's also the voice and then he also--
[Conan] He's very proud of those, by the way.
BoJack Horseman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(crowd cheering)
I kind of took
like a hodgepodge of those three things
and put that into Garmadon to try and fill
that very big throat of Will Arnett.
[Conan] Yes, yes.
[Kumail Nanjiani] What?
Yeah.
(laughter)
You're trying to fill the big throat of Will Arnett?
Yeah, yeah.
You're misinterpreting what I'm saying.
How should I interpret that?
I just wanted to fill Will Arnett's throat.
Alright.
This will not be misinterpreted or turn into a meme.
Don't worry about it.